we are hyped for hockey season and UNLV
Rebel hockey is ready to drop the puck
here to give us a preview of the
upcoming season is the director of Rebel
hockey booster club Michael Turner
welcome thank you for having me what an
exciting season that we have ahead of us
of skating Rebels they are back how's
the team looking this year uh anything
less than a national championship for us
is
going to be tough we are you're so you
guys are ranked second in the country
right now and but that should turn into
first because what just happened uh over
the past weekend up in Colorado we we
knocked off UCO who we lost to in the
semifinals in the national championship
last year uh we beat him on this past
Sunday 5-2 so oh man this is so exciting
now last season I know that it ended
very well where where did they end up
ranked uh we ended up finishing fourth
in the nation we lost in the semifinals
of the National Championship in St Louis
and uh we're looking forward to getting
back to the National Championship this
year oh what an exciting season this is
going to be and also an exciting season
as a fan where you can actually check
out the skate and Rebels and they're
going to be playing in some fun venues
they normally uh skate at City National
and you've got games there but where
else are they going to be playing so
this weekend we open up at the Dollar
Loan Center which is uh really exciting
for us the boys haven't been inside that
Arena yet and we're looking forward to
getting in there and playing there in
same place as The Silver Knights if you
are looking for a fun night out to check
out some true Talent you gotta check out
these guys how how do people get tickets
if they want to see this game so the
Dollar Loan Center game is at the Dollar
Loan Center is where the tickets are and
the rest of the games are through
rebelhockey.com now they're actually
very affordable too yeah so uh the
Dollar Loan Center games tickets start
at 15 and the rest of our home games
it's five dollars to come and see us
play now you coach too right yes I have
a little T I have a 10U team okay so
what proper way to hold the hockey stick
because when I try it at the games I
don't hold it right I hold it like a
brew ah so you want to get your hand
down so you get more power from your
wrist and then you the flick of the
wrist flick of the wrist okay who are
some of the big names on the team that
we should look out for so we have a
couple sets of brothers that are on the
team we have the Johnson Brothers that
are on the team and we also have the
Wyatt brothers that are on the team and
uh we have a lot of kids that are coming
back for their fifth year due to the
coven so it'll be a really exciting and
we're looking forward to it yeah you
definitely want to check them out this
is like you said uh this this is going
to be a national championship I'm
feeling it in my bones we don't want to
like it we don't want to jinx anything
but it sounds great again if people want
to get tickets where do they go uh
rebelhockey.com for any of our normal
games in the Dollar Loan Center uh
website for this weekend Friday night
game we're also hosting University of
Alaska in November at the Dollar Loan
Center who's also a division one team so
they play up a division than us and uh
we're looking forward to having them in
at the Dollar Loan Center what an
exciting season I cannot wait so excited
thank you so much for tuning
this is going to be great make sure you
support those skate and Rebels Kendall
I'll send it over to you